hey I'm Ryan hey I'm aria and we're
gonna be reviewing Maleficent the new
movie starring Angelina Jolie just first
impressions Arielle what do you think
overall I really enjoyed it
um I thought Angelina Jolie was amazing
mm-hmm and I thought just what fantasy
world that they create was beautiful
yeah I agree with you um overall I
enjoyed the film as well I do have some
reservations that we will get into and
just so you know there will be like
spoilers but this is not really like a
spoiler every movie the highlight of the
movie is Angelina Jolie yeah I mean
she's obviously the star she's on all
the posters she's one of the most famous
people alive but no couldn't keep my
eyes off of her yeah it's true like not
being a huge fan of hers in general like
I acknowledges she's very beautiful and
like she's been good in movies I I've
never found her so magnetic as she is in
this movie and I don't know if it's just
the prosthetics it's I feel like to mix
of like the prosthetics of the look of
the film and her performance like should
not be underestimated she's really
really strong in this and plays a lot of
different levels yeah you really see the
progression of her character she starts
out as a very beautiful elegant fairy
and she has these gorgeous big bird-like
wings
you know as the story progresses you get
to kind of understand why she becomes
this evil character more more
misunderstood but you know you really
see like what motivates her as a
character the special effects and the
makeup and just kind of the overall
aesthetic of the movie is the strongest
aspect of it I really brought the whole
world to life
I think totally the movies a little
messy I think that they couldn't quite
decide whether they wanted to make like
kind of a fun enchanting movie or a kind
of dark yeah it kind of feels stuffed
between this PG pg-13 and I would have
liked to see either full versions we
actually looked at our tickets because
we couldn't remember his in he J pg-13
it kind of seems like Disney is trying
to rewrite all their wrongs in the past
yeah movies that they've done so they're
kind of is like a frozen ask you know
twist on it and we're in the end it's
not the Prince that saves Aurora from
the enchantment or the curse it's
actually Maleficent
yeah and
no muffins love for the child that
breaks the curse and I thought that that
was a really nice progression in the
movie you watched she watches a row we
watch her watch aurora grow up
yeah and it's this really really sweet
kind of relationship that develops and I
think that that's really nice Elle
Fanning as usual is very strong in the
movie but again the star of the movie is
Angelina Jolie I'm like she is the best
thing about it yeah she's like I think
that this is kind of I enjoyed the movie
if I don't know if though it made a lot
of money this weekend on the pill trying
to franchise this a sequel I don't think
you could don't find a way they will
find a way but we obviously recommend
the movie again it's a little dark for
little kids so like a great time there
are a lot of kids in a theater and I
think they enjoyed it and then there was
a round of applause at the end yeah
clearly liked it so but yeah it's just a
little violent they take it from two
people who aren't parents you know just
be responsible um until next time
comment below let us know what you
thought of molestin i'm ryan i'm erielle
thank you